you
thank you sir hello everybody thank you
for our introduction so I am senior
staff software engineer at LinkedIn here
in New York City and I wanted to sort of
talk today about something that might
have been useful to me and my team when
we were setting out to build this
project so that's kind of the
perspective from which I'm going to be
talking about and yes I am in New York I
live and work in New York I don't have
to travel remotely too often we have an
engineering team about 40 people now
that's our t-shirt that's our mascot and
we are we are hiring thanks Peter
and the work the project I'm presenting
today it was work of a team that wasn't
just me so one of the other colleagues
David he's here in the audience as well
he can bug him later and it's
collaboration between the contingent
team which is the team in New York and
the search network analytics team or the
data science team which is located in
Mountain View but we're getting our own
- one of my other colleagues Xiao Cheng
is around here or he's probably on the
data science track so what would
motivate us to actually go get data from
the web right so our dream is to help
people more easily navigate the sort of
global economy right and the idea there
is to create an economic graph sort of a
first digital map of global economy
you know and that will help us kind of
help people find opportunities in the
world and so what makes up this graph
right so it's member profiles company
profiles job skills schools that kind of
stuff right and LinkedIn has a lot of
this right like we have 400 million
members we have you know several million
profiles for companies you know millions
of jobs skills all that stuff but
there's quite a bit more of all of this
stuff out on the internet right like we
don't have all of this data a lot of it
is out there
you know how many people here have a
LinkedIn profile alright so mote Wow
great penetration excellent so most
people here do great how many people
here update their LinkedIn profile for
reasons other than looking for a job or
having just acquired a new job yeah you
see so that's the thing right because
there's lots more things that are
happening the world right you publish a
paper you presented a conference you
know that kind of stuff people tend not
to necessarily do that online profile so
we wanted to help with that right how
many people here have worked for company
has a page on LinkedIn like a LinkedIn
company page right so that's another
thing how many people here have a job on
their company page but not a job on
LinkedIn like the job posting on company
patient on LinkedIn right like so these
are the kind of things that problems
solve this is what we want to work
around it and so we had this big idea
right like of course we need to crawl
the entire web of course we need to get
all this stuff in real time we need to
pull it all in and we need to get it up
there as quickly as possible right so
this is the original big idea so throw
30,000 QPS of web pages at our you know
Samsa cluster you know pumping all these
message in there using Kafka that gives
us two point five nine billion pages per
day rate and we would crawl the web and
you know everything be great and then
we'd filter out all the stuff near line
using Samsa using sense of processes
that would filter the data down to like
a manageable a thousand pages per second
you know and that would be like only 86
million new objects per day you know and
would be great and we'd be done crawling
the the entire internet and like you
know six months or something and that
was sort of great idea and it was it was
inspired influenced by this paper that
talks about a potential architecture for
extendable web crawler and the idea of
this paper is that you kind of know your
queries ahead of time so we know the
companies we know the people we know the
skills the jobs so we have the search
queries ahead of time so you can kind of
pre compute what your search results
would be as a data streaming through
that's
this paper and you know it's kind of if
it has it has legs right
the folks do this kind of stuff for you
know filtering packages are coming
through the network so it's viable to do
something like this and then we kind of
went to pitch this big idea to other
colleagues and they help us focus our
vision right they asked a bunch of
questions you know you know who would
use this tool do we need to crawl the
entire web right given that only so much
of it is actually useful to us
do we need to process pages near line or
like you know in the streaming fashion
do we need you know where would we store
a list data right the Internet is big
you know like really big lots of data
and who how would we correct mistakes in
our flow right if we were doing this if
we're doing stream processing right
where the data retention is kind of
shorter than if you had it in some
permanent storage how would you correct
that system right how would you fix
mistakes in your model fix mistakes in
your processes so the who would use this
product was answered by the identity
team linked and this is a team that
manages the profile so your LinkedIn
profile and all the different services
are related to that that's managed by
the identity team and it turns out the
most value proposition to members so
people who have a LinkedIn or on account
is related to your profile right if your
profile is more complete than it's
easier to find you with search queries
so it's easier for opportunities to sort
of find you this is how recruiters would
find you on LinkedIn this is how they
would reach out to people who might not
who you know right depends on you how
full your profile is that all those
relationships need to be captured to do
that and sort of establishing yourself
as somebody who's a thought leader in
industry you know you can display that
on your LinkedIn profile you know so
it's all kind of central to things in
profile however doing this on on a
mobile device sort of updating your
profile model device is a little bit
tricky right it's kind of tricky doing
it on your desktop most of you from the
audience don't really keep your profile
up-to-date right on the mobile phone
even more challenging because it's hard
to enter all the stuff in right so the
idea that the identity team had is to
have a smarter way to build your profile
right go out find content that you would
be proud to share in your LinkedIn
profile that's part of your professional
identity bring it to you and say hey it
looks like you just spoke at this
conference or hey it looks like you
published this paper in the science
journal or the nature right attitude
LinkedIn profile complete your identity
and then sort of you like press a button
say yes it's me yes these are my
co-authors and there you go it's on your
profile no typing so that's the kind of
use case we were trying to solve for
them so we talked to them to understand
what the use case is and because
Coughlin's sounds a featured prominently
or our initial sort of idea our design
we went to speak to those teams and so
there was a talk here yesterday on Kafka
and a bunch of people familiar on Kafka
so who knows what Kafka is all right so
in general just an abstraction like it's
a distributed commit log right it's
basically there's a producer they create
a bunch of messages as a consumer that
reads and messages from from the log
they're kind of decoupled from each
other and that's sort of in general very
briefly Kafka and nobody yesterday
didn't seem to know what samsø is how
many people know what Samsa is okay so
I'll briefly describe that as well so
say you have these Kafka consumers and
producers right and say you want to tie
up a bunch of them so I produce
something that I have a consumer that
processes it and produces another event
and so forth right you can kind of chain
these things together now you can do
that manually right you can set up the
producer and consumer and then you can
put in check sums and figure out where
you fell fell over and how to recover
right so Samsa is a framework that lets
you make that happen without having to
worry about all the different concerns
that are involved in doing that it lets
you tie together all these different
message queues to produce the result and
also has some local storage to write
which you need to take care of your own
and at LinkedIn cough concerns are
by an operating operations team right
they're responsible for I'm making sure
the clusters are up and running that
they're healthy that there's no lag
doesn't delay you know like all the hard
drives are spinning in an optimal way
and so we went to talk to them about our
use case right and it turned out that
our use case was not a perfect fit for
this specifically the the average size
of an HTML page which is the stuff that
we'd be sending through here is about 6
K and according to to our HTTP archive
org
the you know like most of them are
bigger than that right so only 10% are
less than 10 K 37% less than 10 K and so
but generally by messages you send
through Kafka kind of small messages
right there and they're not on this size
and Sansa has no problem handling the
workload we're gonna throw it right we
were gonna say something like 30 TPS
right which is nothing there's
experiments that show like 1.2 million
no million messages per node per per
second right like it's incredibly high
throughput so that wasn't problem but
the size of the type of data we're
throwing was and the other problem is
data retention right so Sam's are kind
of relies on Hadoop or on Kafka to keep
track to keep the data the messages
right and you can kind of replay from
Kafka to repopulate your Sam's uh
processes so where would we store all
this data right that's a lot of pages a
lot of data that wasn't necessarily a
good fit then another thing is we didn't
really know how we're gonna match
members right so the we didn't have a
model built yet and kind of trying to
train a model a build a model or without
knowing what it is in Sam's it would be
challenging and one of the things that
one of the reasons Samsa it's so fast
and performed so well is because it adds
some constraints to your implementation
one of the constraints is it's not like
a hard constraint but it's an advice
advice that you get is that you don't
want to make remote calls to remote
databases if you need data on your
processor you want to store that data
locally on the same node as you are
going to process that data so that means
is if you want to get data from some
external database you actually copy it
replicated into your Sam's a cluster
right so you take your database and you
basically replay it as kafka messages
into the sam's of cluster it's a viable
option right because you can process
billions of messages in really short
time right or millions of messages in a
really short time and you can build up
the database you can go locally but you
still have to do that that's the last
step that you need to do and once again
if you don't know what part of the data
you need it's kind of hard to do that
ahead of time right so not not a good
fits though so that's bootstrapping you
so we spoke to them and we spoke to your
identity team and we came up with this
project Satori now Satori is a Japanese
Buddhist term talks about like awakening
or comprehension understanding sort of
like enlightenment roughly translated
and what we want to do is lace or
lighten our 400 million members write
help them realize their professional
identity and LinkedIn and we were gonna
find source of professional content
right stuff that you'd be proud to have
on your profile from the public Internet
that's available out there grab it
extracted structured and then match it
to member profiles right that's that's
the idea so we went ahead and tried to
figure out you know we as a team we had
expertise in fetching data right we
operate like a sharing back-end here so
you drop a URL we fetch the data we knew
how to do that we had some expertise
with doob MapReduce and we had some
folks who had experience with machine
learning but we never put the whole
thing together right and there's like
and we turned out that this kind of
problem that we're trying to solve is
known as web data extraction right and
for web big extraction you know there's
lots of different ways to kind of think
about how do it and there's a great
survey paper that documents familiar
Ferrar that kind of documents the
different techniques and the different
ways that web data extraction is used so
you saw an example today right the
Spotify folks just earlier talked about
how they go through blog posts and news
posts and they get
their data about artists right it's sort
of a social use case social web use case
right they want to get this information
to enrich their own applications there
are enterprise use cases right if you
want to find out your competitors
pricing you go scrape their website find
out I'm not advocating that just that's
just a use case and they talked about
the different use cases the different
sources of data rights something that's
like intranet versus Internet and bulk
data or search data then we talked about
how you would get about getting this
data right do you have a full browser do
you have something that's programmable
do you have a crawler those are
different pieces that they talk about
and they also talk about this idea of
wrappers all right and how different
people decided to wrap web pages to get
data out of them right and there's they
talk about tree similarity using X paths
specific programming languages for this
purpose or generic programming language
that you use to to implement this
purpose right they talked about this I'm
gonna dig in a little bit more about
wrappers right so not candy wrappers but
to where wrappers so that's an example
of actually web wrapper implementation
it's just JSON data and the way they
define web data in survey the way to
define web data extra procedure that
might implement one of many different
classes of algorithms which seek to find
data required by human user extract from
from instructors a semi structured web
resources and transforming them into
structured data merging and unifying
this information for further processing
and semi-automated a fully automatic way
okay was that helpful
all right so so what it actually is is
think of it as an inverse function on
your template that was used to render
the web page right so there's some
database underneath the covers there's a
template that is filled in with that
data and a wrapper is a way to like
remove the template just get the data
back out and store it in your own
databases right inverse function on a
web page and it can be you can implement
however right you can imagine writing
this as a Python script or a Java code
or whatever right to do it
you can use XPath CSS selectors to get
the data out as well right
but however or you can just parse the
Dom tree but however you gonna do it
you're gonna have this problem that you
have some you have written some code
some implementation right and you did an
extraction but now the page changed so
you have to you have to constantly kind
of catch up and make sure that you're a
function is the same function as they're
using or the universe of the function
that they're using on the other end it's
kind of a painful process it's not a
painful process if you're going after
like five sites or two sites or one site
but it's a painful process for going
after thousands or millions of sites and
that's where our aspirations lie so it's
good to get actually some industrial
research on this since you were doing
Yahoo actually Yahoo research published
a lot of work and they did a lot of
research to figure out how to build this
for their scale right so they figured
out how to induce wrappers from the data
right so you don't actually write any
wrappers yourself you look at the data
and you figure out what how you can
extract structured data from here right
in an automated way if they build
wrappers that are robust right so they
actually went ahead and analyzed how
data changes over time on the web and
how the structure of the webpage changes
and what parts are likely to be added or
removed right and then decided that if
you build your XPath expression in such
a way that you don't include divs for it
for example you're less likely to break
that active half expression in the
future so it's the work they did they
also figured out how to cluster similar
pages based just on the URLs right so
you're going to build this wrapper it's
going to apply to a particular data
source particular set of pages you need
to figure out what those pages are so
you can both figure out how to build
wrapper on top of it and apply it
effectively and they did one other
interesting study they analyzed the
structured data on the internet and
actually turned out that we as users a
more interest are interested in stuff
that's out on the long tail so the long
tail of the data is important you can
get the data from like the top sites but
our interest for information
just the top sites you really have to go
deep deep into the long tail in order to
get information that we are still
interested in its users now the reason
they were able to do all this great work
is because they actually had all this
great data right they had a crawler they
operated a search engine and they were
able to kind of execute or do all their
research all their analysis on an
existing set of web pages that they had
internally we at LinkedIn didn't have
existing web page internally so the next
step in the process was to pick a web
crawler and you know as every
engineering team out there you go
through this sort of like a set of
decisions that you want to make when
picking your work earlier oh yeah we can
build our own how difficult could it be
it's a web crawler you know just
glorified you know curl with a you know
a job on the side and that's it the web
crawling done right you can use
something that somebody else at LinkedIn
is using and we had other use cases or
you could go back to you know community
to figure out what are the
recommendations for for this project so
there's once again you go to research
community there's going to be a survey
paper and you can read it and really get
up to speed quickly on what this
particular thing that you want to build
is like so there's a paper that talks
about web wrapping and the circa 2010 it
was like the state of the art of wrapper
what of crawlers at the time not
Reverend but crawlers at the time right
and you know reading about what the
state of the art is and what are all
different concerns so managing data
selecting the next set of pages to crawl
how to do this all efficiently and
effectively right so all of this kind of
made us reconsider building one on our
own like okay yeah looks like a
difficult problem probably don't want to
spend all our resources just on this
there's actual project to deliver
problems to solve
somebody internally was using scrappy
and scrappy sort of a framework that
lets you automate like Python scripts
that you use to actually extract the
structured data but it's all written in
Python right and the operating program
and the team had it but they weren't
really
getting new use cases on to it so that
wasn't really an option for us now and
we were sort of looking for a particular
set of things right we are mostly Java
engineers LinkedIn has a big Java
deployment I would say most of the
engineers in Java
more than weigh more than 50% engineers
at Java engineers we needed something it
was open source had a had a good license
right and apache license is something
like this and something you didn't
require a lot of operational overhead
right so the contestants were hair
tricks which is something that powers
archive.org notch which is something
that powers come and crawl and bugging
which is part of law library I think
it's a library of algorithms for the web
and we went ahead and looked at them so
all three of these were sorry oh man all
three of these were Java projects open
sourced different licenses you know
difference between like Apache and GL 3
new version 3
so Hara tricks doesn't have like a
distributed mode hair tricks you can run
on on one service and you can kind of
limit how how that works you can you can
tell it you are only responsible for
these domains and then it will actually
find pages that not knows domains it
kind of spill them into the file and you
can copy that file to the different
machines that is responsible for dummies
but that doesn't kind of come out of the
box it just exists you need to in to
operate they need to build it nut is
implementing Java open sourced and is
under Apache License and it is
implemented top of Hadoop MapReduce so
if you already have a new MapReduce
system in place it's kind of a good
choice to go after and then bubble was
the sort of like it had distributed it
was really fast according to the
research but there wasn't a way to get
the source code so the binary was
available at the source code wasn't and
to do distribute accomplish distributed
coordination between the different
crawlers using J groups and Henry do you
ever use J groups here
or like Jay and I Ginny it's like a
framework for communicating between
devices Java like circa 1998 or
something so it wasn't necessarily a you
know from from from our perspective
wasn't like the freshest technology so
to speak so we actually went ahead and
installed each one of these right so
nuts and hair tricks we got up in a
couple of hours and we were able to
execute a crawl bubbling we gave up
after a day or two
we couldn't configure all the different
requirements that it needed to to get
running on a machine so just already
shipped us the winner was not right so
it it helped us with certain so it's
written in Java so we were able to read
or understand it see the source code it
uses HDFS for storage right and we at
LinkedIn have already a large deployment
for Hadoop deployment right so HDFS is
easily available and we don't didn't
need to worry about getting up machines
or getting up reliable stories or
replicating stories none of that stuff
right we can just put this data on HDFS
and not worry about it it allowed it to
leverage existing infrastructure it was
proven to work by common crawl they
execute these massive crawls you know
billions and billions and billions of
objects so so that's great means we
would be able to scale it even if we
knew from you too even though we didn't
need to initially and we were able to
orchestrate
so not just basically a collection of
jobs that work together and we were able
to orchestrate it with Azkaban and
Azkaban is a sort of Hadoop job
scheduling tool that LinkedIn has open
source that's available for everybody
and the interesting bit of trivia is
that Hadoop was actually refactored out
of knotch so the folks that were
building much actually we're building
MapReduce distributed file systems thing
inside it and people said oh well
besides much besides sort of building a
general way to crawl the web there's
actually it's really useful algorithm
and there's really no implementation
side here we'll pull it out and make
that could you prime so that's that's
the origins if we do so now the actual
implementation of Satori which is the
project the application of
of the use case for identity and having
not you're operating on HDFS so this is
our sort of general Kroll flow right
this is a diagram produced from Azkaban
just a job flow diagram so this is build
on notch 1.9 runs on Hadoop 2 3 that we
have this float scheduled to run every 5
hours that's actually a kind of a an
important thing to to look at you want
to make sure that you want to crawl as
as often phones as much of your time as
you want as you can you want to spend
fetching data that's going to be your
sort of challenge right because you need
to respect robots.txt you need to be
able to make sure that you don't
overload the system right so crawling is
going to be slow
the default crawl the default in in
knots and default is like you fetch a
page every 5 seconds right so only 12
pages per second so you have this sort
of it takes a while to do it we
implemented we were able to focus our
crawl so we really needed just
publications so we went out and found a
bunch of sites that make publication
data really easily available and instead
of trying to have a crawl that fills out
a form for a particular topic and then
that goes ahead and gives us a bunch of
URLs we just iterated the URLs we were
able to see the pattern the URLs and you
were able to enumerate all of them and
just take that and throw that at not as
a seed set of URLs and let it go go to
work on top of it and we were we want it
to be sort of good stewards of the
Hadoop cluster as well right so you
imagine this is very different workload
than your other Hadoop workflow right
none of the data is actually stored
locally when you're doing fetching
you're actually going out on the
internet and fetching all these
documents and when you fetch these
documents right they have a latency
associated with them you know way slower
than you know disk local reads right
this is going over in the network going
out onto the public Internet who knows
with late seas there right so you want
to be careful
how you do it and nudge gives you some
ways to tune how you perform these right
first of all it lets you control how
many fetchers you have basically you
know each you control the number of
mappers that you allocate to this job
and that gives you sort of the number of
machines that will be doing the fetching
and then on top of that you can control
how many threads you have running per
machine and one thread on that map are
basically maps to one site that you want
to get data from and that's how they
that's how much implements making sure
that you respect robots.txt and you
don't overwhelm a site so you tune that
and you can also tune how many pages you
try to fetch in one go and then you can
figure out when you want to cut off your
fetch job and here's also an interesting
balancing act because there will be
sites that are really fast and they
serve pages really quickly and then
we'll be sites that are really slow or
slow you down with their crawl delay
declaration in robots.txt so you want to
make sure that you fetch the fast ones
as quickly as you can but you know you
don't have to wait for the slow ones to
finish up so the way we solve that
problem we're not supposed to do is just
cut off the fetch job and say ok after n
hours just stop running this job so the
N hours we picked was four hours and
that allowed us to have like sort of
five hour window between this job
running and not interrupting itself ok
and one more thing that I want to note
here there are actually two different
branches of nuts
there's the 1x branch and the 2x
branches they're not it's not like an
upgrade it's a replacement basically I
mean they came out from the same ideas
but they're actually very different
implementations and the 2x branch bits
advantages you can use something other
than HDFS for storage we didn't really
need that advantage so we went with 1/9
but we did go ahead and output the
results of our crawl in the same format
as the nacha 2.0 version does so they
have this schema called the web page
it's narrow schema we output the same
average kheema web page so if we ever
wanted to switch out the crawler for the
new version would be able to do it
without impact to downstream calls
and it's linked in everything is an
average stored in HDFS is an avro format
so this kind of fit well with with our
existing tooling so this is the the
extract flow right so once you've
finished fetch fetching you want to go
ahead and extract and this is where we
apply our wrappers right and our
wrappers our represent the schema that
we are outputting the data in right so
if we're outputting a publication the
scheme the output schema of the subject
that we apply when we apply the wrapper
to a page will be a publication the way
it also captures which page it applies
to by doing URL pattern matching so you
know the wrapper that was designed for
PubMed would say this is a PubMed
wrapper I want extract data from these
URLs and then we use XPath to sort of
fill out the fields so publication has
an author a title and abstract and we
have an XPath selector to pick the data
from the page from the from the field
and pull that it sets our wrapper and
then the initially when we first
implemented we had the the fetch and the
extract flow in one kind of giant flow
which was really nice because he never
had to worry about when are you done
processing all the pages you just
fetched you kind of just you know it's
when the flow completes right but the
disadvantage of that is you were
spending time on extracting data and
indexing data that you could have been
spending time on fetching data and
fetching is the sort of the long pole
right like that's the thing that's gonna
consume most of your time most of your
resources so you want to do it so we
were able to split this up and another
advantage that this gave us splitting
them up this way is that we were now
able to re-implement or re extract all
the data without interrupting the fetch
process so we can continuously fetch
without ever stopping that job and just
keep going in the loops and re-executing
the fetch flow and then if we decided to
change the schema for our wrappers or we
decided to change the schema for our
output objects whatever it is right we
could just empower I'll start re running
the extraction job and go ahead and
basically a
fix on any mistakes or make any changes
that we wanted to do without ever
interrupting the fetch which was
actually you know a great thing I were
able to do and we wound up actually
doing that a couple of times because few
engineers changed their minds and
sometimes you need to erase and rewrite
another thing that we took care of is
the way we indexed at LinkedIn we have a
verb data and we have this sort of
format for every data that we have we
have it indexed by the type of data it
is followed by the you know daily or
hourly and then sort of the year month
day or year month day hour right so we
indexed it the same way as well and that
enabled us to use all the other tools
that we have a LinkedIn for this kind of
stuff and the second thing we did is we
prepended that with a host right so all
our data is in text by the domain the
web domain from which it's coming
followed by this timestamp and that's
important because if you ever need to
delete the data because you got a you
know I see the desist or somehow you
need to get rid of this data from your
infrastructure you can just delete the
data from that host and not worry about
affecting any of the other files right
versus if you had a one one big blob
then you kind of have to write a job
that would rewrite the entire block as
useful never had to use it but we put it
in place so some lessons learned from
here and kind of said it maybe five
times already but nonetheless crawl rate
is bound by the number of sites and the
site's crawl delay right so this is the
thing it's gonna be slow for example
there was a site that we encountered
that had a crawl delay of 30 seconds so
basically you could fetch only two pages
per minute right and we wanted to get
120 thousand pages from there so that
would equate to a thousand crawl hours
just to get data from this one site so
you and typical crawl delay is about
five seconds so only twelve pages per
minute right so it's really really slow
right we're talking about usually we
expect QPS in the thousand but this is
really slow so you can increase crawl
rate by just getting a bunch more sites
right like you find sites that have this
data and just as many of them
you can that's how you're going to
increase your crawl rate but there is
also problem you're going to be bound by
the type of data you're looking for so
not everybody has this data for you and
how constraint they are about the data
right so ResearchGate
actually doesn't let any robots on to
its site so you wouldn't be able to get
research to gate to expand your data set
so there's another solution to this you
can bootstrap from bulk sources right so
I mentioned common crawl before great
source of data they have you know they
continuously do these crawls and if you
want to bootstrap a search engine if you
want to do that common Crowell would be
a go-to place to go to get all that data
it's really useful and to bootstrap you
can use Goblin another open source
framework by LinkedIn which is really
good at pulling we use it a lot
internally to pull our like kafka
streams into HDFS or to pull our
databases into HDFS but you can
definitely use the to pull data from
external sites and we do so as well you
know we used it to get data from common
crawl and PubMed which are available in
bulk formats and this is they pulls it
right onto your HDFS storage which is
really nice if that's what you need it
another thing is XPath extractors can
get challenging on sites with rich data
models for example for human when you
read a paper you have the authors and
you have little suffix that shows their
affiliation so as a human you understand
oh this person must be affiliated with
this University but an HTML looks like
two parallel arrays with with the with
the index being the index into the array
it's not at all clear how you'd figure
that out with an XPath wrapper
additionally XML is great but it's not
always available if some sites will
explicitly not let you crawl their XML
version of the document and other sites
does this one really funny it shows you
things it looks like you seem XML but if
you look at it actually escaped XML so
just like you know greater than less
than M percent signs all over the place
it looks really strange okay and another
thing that we learned kind of later on
but we did eventually learn it is it's
really easy to exceed Hadoop quota so we
are using at LinkedIn Hadoop is sort of
infrastructure like everything else so
there a quote in place to make sure that
you don't exceed it you can definitely
do it every fetch cycle produces a bunch
of files that's just part of how notch
works so you'll be generating ton of
files if you do in continuous fetch loop
so just remember to clean them up
there's a segment merge tool in in nuts
that you can use to actually merge or
the different segments into one bigger
segment and behave better as a customer
of this ok so now we got the data
fetched parsed extracted and indexed
only the simple problem remains to
mention to remember profile right so
this is where our you know match off
there's publications to members to power
profile at experience right so this is
where the machine learning part of this
comes in and the basic job is here's
this paper published on +1 by Charles
here this Charles profile you know match
him figure out that this paper was
published by Charles and asks Charles to
go ahead and publish it on Joanna
Terry's LinkedIn profile and the
overview of system is kind of
straightforward this is what you would
see in a typical production system you
have this flow once you train the model
you extract the feature vectors you
apply the model scores and then you get
this matched data you do it the first
part there is candidate 10 in selection
as an interesting part and then you can
once you've done that you can actually
once you have the data on HDFS you can
sample that data to do training locally
on your machine right so our data
scientist were able to do the training
part offline in our so we started simple
right it turns out that it's really
useful when you can use global
identifier to match data so publications
sometimes have emails and sometimes they
have full names linkedin has emails and
full names so the first model is really
straightforward you could do match by
email precisely and then that wasn't
enough because the data kind of is dirty
so you could then do fuzzy name matching
and this shows that you know we had I
think point eight three precision just
by
email but when you do email plus fuzzy
name matching and the algorithms didn't
really matter how you did the fuzzy
string matching you got like you know
point nine nine so really accurate right
and the value of this is you can you can
do this right and then you can get the
matches really quickly really well and
they can actually put it in front of the
people who can use this data and the
members and they can validate whether
your idea and the matching is good so
first you can validate that you do the
right match and you find in the wrong
people
second you can validate that you're
actually doing the correct that the
product is useful right you can show it
to the people and you can say oh yeah
this is useful I would like to add this
to my profile alright so then next step
was so not everybody in a publication
has an email right so the bunch of
publication is not enough email so that
motivated the example of building a
better matching algorithm that doesn't
just rely on email however we were able
to use the email matches to actually
generate you know a data set a data set
of people who we knew match correctly
and then once we knew that the email
match worked through validation from the
members we also knew that we could apply
the email a matching technique to the
rest of our data to generate a training
set for a more advanced model right so
we're able to generate a training set of
a couple hundred thousand records from
the data we had for the more advanced
model and then just trained a linear
resistive regression to go ahead and and
and and do the implementation do the
matching using data from the profile now
the first thing that was kind of an
interesting challenge to solve is you
you know any member could have published
any paper so you have 400 million
members 20 million member 20 million
papers now you multiply them you have a
huge data set to kind of try to do
pairwise matching right so really neat
trick you use LSH so locally sensitive
hashing to buy full name to match the
people publishers from the paper to the
member profiles and now you have a much
smaller candidate set like orders of
magnitude smaller candidate set now this
is this name disambiguation in academia
is by itself a deep research topic you
can imagine most of digital libraries
don't have full name
they have just first name and last name
so if your last name is f10 you've not a
lot of problem disambiguating but if
your last name is Smith or Lee or shin
like forget it it's gonna be a lot of
common names to get rid of so the
logistic regression got us pretty far
and we were able to get 0.89 precision
recall so a really good match to get the
data down and then there's some
interesting features that came up that
we used in our model but there was a lot
of them look like a couple of hundred so
only list row them but some of them were
interesting so max names similarity was
a strong indication of strong feature
that we were able to use members in the
medical industry you know medical
professional publish a lot useful
feature affiliation matching between
members so your affiliation on the paper
and your LinkedIn profile data was a
strong match and high as degree as a PhD
strong match for for research
publication apparently you have to
publish a paper to become a PhD and
there were a few interesting negative
coefficient features of negative
coefficients as well one of them is
highest degrees in MBA so apparently to
get an MBA you don't have to publish
research or the opposite and another one
was that members in the banking industry
apparently if you're in banking industry
you don't tend to publish your work okay
so what's our current status so after
about six months of work we were able to
get you know we have a bunch of
publication we can still go after so
fifty six thousand publications that we
pages with publication Ilham Emily we
can still fetch writes a lot of data we
fetched five thousand and a million of
them are so there's a million sorry we
fetched five million a million of gone
so fifty six million still to crawl like
I said crawling is very slow right I
would love to for that line to be like
way down there but and then we also
started crawling companies right we were
able to apply our wrapper logic for
publications so lots of different sites
lots of different wrappers but now we
want to go to different domain so
companies for companies would get like
addresses location name that kind of
stuff so companies we just start it's
only two million and we targeted much
tighter so to millions still left to go
and
point five million we already pulled
pulled the information for and once we
did we applied to do the extraction
rights extraction is also not perfect
we got three point nine million
publications extracted of five point
three and we just started doing
extraction now on companies so just not
even a million yet so some lessons
learned from this target the data
sources which have the data that you
need and you'd be really easy to get the
data from right so get after those first
it will help you prove your use case
prove your ability to actually do it
prove out your tooling prove out your
operations add tracking to the entire
flow right you want to figure out where
you got this data from how you were able
to match it to this member and what did
the member say when you showed it to
them right the entire flow you want to
get that done it helps you you know
figure out how you're doing with the
progress helps you do some reporting on
it helps you feedback into the machine
learning and training to be able to get
a better algorithm do all of this of
line if you can right the huge advantage
we had didn't need to worry about
procuring storage nodes didn't need to
worry about retention in in the Kafka or
anything of that sort and we were able
to rerun our extraction over and over
and over again every time we had a
problem that we needed to fix really
useful and HDFS of course does
replication for you and all that stuff
right and then sort of get the product
to the customers early validate the
process and the value proposition right
we we got we send this as an email test
and this was sort of one of the most
successful marketing emails we were sent
out by conversion rate so people
actually read the email then went to the
page and then clicked yes please add
this to my profile automatically really
useful most important write it all down
and share it with everybody because
that's how you know we can figure out
how to build the next better system and
how to leverage somebody's else's work
that's it thank you
sorry that I sped up there at the end we
have a few minutes for questions
how do you handle single page
applications where you can't get the
HTML or the data by crawler sure so how
do you handle sending up applications
google recently published this protocol
to let you share single page
applications as permalink right and they
have it's a hash bang I think it's like
exclamation point and a hash sign so
bang hash and when you see that it
actually expands out into a URL that you
can hit the Ajax page and most of the
single page applications that care about
SEO so basically anybody who'd be able
to access with the crawler anyway
implement that protocol to make sure
that Google can can get that data so
just to make sure you implement that
protocol as well there are some folks
that use like a browser like they pull
up a phantom j/s or something in the
background and go ahead and do it that
way and I think Google is starting to
use a Chrome browser to do it so it
might get more difficult in time but for
now this works how the questions right
okay Nicholas will be waiting in the
hunter room in case you have further
questions he'll be there for half hour
so you can ask him more questions in
hunter room thank you thank you